We're gonna kick it off by tackling a topic
that I am truly fascinated with.
And it's dating.
Because I am convinced that no matter what in life,
you are contending and wrestling with
and finessing and working through a relationship.
I don't care who it's with,
you're in a relationship with something.
It could be your dog, your grandmother, your sister,
your mother, your brother, your best friend, your husband,
your wife,
we're all trying to figure out a, or multiple relationships.
And when it comes to dating,
I feel that behavior is really become my number one thing
that I like to dissect and discuss.
So is anyone here a dating, this situation,
anyone dating in the wall?
Marina?
Hi Marina.
So I am in a long distance relationship.
My boyfriend lives in England and I live in Florida.
It's incredibly difficult.
Not only the time difference, the time that we'd been apart,
and we have no idea when we're going to see each other next.
How long have you been dating?
We have been together for about a year.
And what is your end game?
I mean, we've talked about a life together.
It's incredibly, you know, difficult,
especially right now, 'cause we just
have no clue what's going on.
Also, we're kind of in a challenging profession.
We met working on a cruise ship.
So we both work on cruise ships with our contract lengths,
and you know, sometimes I'm on one side of the world
and he's on the other side of the world.
And so that makes it even more challenging.
Okay, so maybe when your industry resumes,
life resumes for all of us.
So right now you are in a purgatory that you cannot control.
Here is the good news
is usually in normal times I'm like long distance?
Great, it'll last that much longer
because when you're in each other's faces 24/7,
it's not good.
That said, when you wanna build a life with someone,
I believe down the road, concessions and you know,
geography and things will have to get sorted out.
But since none of that is within your control right now,
make this the most romantic time.
Write letters, find new ways of communicating,
learn more about each other in inventive,
sexy, cool, fun ways.
Say, "We're gonna make this time count
"in a way it never could have otherwise.
"And then when things go back to a different kind of normal,
"we'll figure out what we can do then
"and take each as it comes."
But for now I say, go for it
and figure out every single, new, unique way
that you two can stay connected
and learn more about each other.
You don't like that advice.
I love that,
thank you so much.
Oh, good, oh good, phew.
(audience laughing)
Literally, like find games that you can play,
like join Words With Friends
and become Scrabble buddies online.
Write love letters to each other, you know,
send care packages, show each other,
say, "I want you to watch this movie tonight,
"and then tomorrow we'll discuss
"'cause it's one of my favorite
"and I can't wait to see what you think."
Get clever.
I love it, thank you so much.
And then you can say, "And when I do see you,
"you better watch out 'cause I'm going and attacking you."
(audience applauds)
(hands clapping)
(Marina laughing)
A little dangle of a promise
and a romantic like finish is so fun.
(audience applauding)
(hands clapping)
Okay.
So that was so fun by the way.
I'm not kidding, I could do this all day long.
I love talking about relationships
and no matter what your age or situation,
dating can always be a challenge.
I mean, look at, you know, what they're going through
due to geography and COVID and everything.
Everybody has challenges in relationships.
And we found some people who are in the midst of struggling
through their dating experience and need some help.
Well, we have certified dating coach
and relationship expert, and very good friend of the show
Damona Hoffman here, to set them up for success.
This is Drew's Love Bug!
(audience applauding)
Hi, Damona!
Hey, good to see you again, Drew.
Damona, you changed my life when you said,
like drop the digital hanky.
I mean, I just, I'm so glad that we're in this together.
And I really like talking about dating advice with you
because you have a calm and a confidence,
that I really think people can benefit from.
Thank you, we have to keep calm and carry on,
and everybody still needs love, especially in today's world.
So let's help some folks out.
Well, when you equate modern romance
to dropping the digital hanky,
I was like, "Yes, that is Jane Austin meets Tinder."
So, Katy here is a familiar experience.
She has a dating burnout situation.
Hi Katy, how are you?
Hi, Drew, I'm good, I'm so excited to be here.
Hi, Damona?
Hello, Katy.
We're so excited that you're here.
Please ask guru Damona a question.
Okay guru Damona, I have very little patience
after I go on, or when I'm on a date,
if it's not working or not clicking,
I'm pretty much like, how soon can I get out of this?
Because I know who I am, I know what I like.
And men are very like, take it or leave it.
If I go on a date, like you better be bringing
something to the table.
So I kind of wanna know, how soon without being cruel
or hurtful, can I be like, "This isn't working, I'm out,"
like it's 20 minutes too soon?
(all laughing)
Because,
I don't have,
I think I don't have the emotional bandwidth
to like endure a date just to be polite, you know?
Yes, I do know, and you do have to conserve
your emotional energy and your time.
Your time is really precious,
so who you spend it with really does matter.
What I would say Katy is,
I think you might be doing things in the reverse order.
You might be skipping a really crucial screening step
that I like to have my clients do.
A video chat date or a phone call
before you even get to the date.
Because if you spend 15 to 20 minutes there,
from the comfort of your own home,
a lot of times you can see what those red flags are.
You can see if you can't really connect
in real time communication,
and you can save yourself a lot of time
by not even going on the date.
Do you ever do these screening calls?
No, but the idea of not even having to go,
(chuckles) is so titillating.
(all laughing)
I just saved you a lot of time, and on top of that,
I think you should come up with a phrase
that you always use when you realize that it's not a match
because sometimes trying to figure out what to say
can also eat up a lot of emotional energy.
So if you just decide, you're always going to say,
"I had a great time getting to know you,
"but I don't feel like it's a match."
That actually is really the most humane thing
you can do to someone, so you're not keeping them
hanging on waiting to see
if you're going to change your mind
or just waiting to get ghosted.
Just go ahead and close that loop,
and honey, you can just move on to the next.
I love this Damona you really are a game changer.
Okay, the next question we have, is Susan
and Susan found herself in a very uncomfortable situation
on a video chat date, funny enough, speaking of.
Susan, I'm so happy you came on the show, thank you.
Well, hi Drew, thanks for having me and hi, Damona.
So I've been dating on and off for the last five years
and as a nana in these modern times, it's tough.
I recently had a nightmare experience
where I was video chatting with a guy
who turned out to be, completely naked.
(all laughing)
I couldn't get a guy to show up on a date
from a dating app, so that's something to celebrate
in a very sick way.
I wanna be, but I also want to make sure
that my standards, boundaries and expectations
are very clear from the start.
So how can I do this with these times of dating apps,
video chats and uninhibited man.
(all laughing)
Wooh!
Oh my goodness, Susan, that is a doozy.
So first of all, I am so sorry that that happened to you.
I'm sure that was really shocking.
And if that ever happens to you again, Susan,
definitely block and report immediately,
the apps take that very seriously,
I hope you did that on the last one.
Then they won't do it to someone else,
but then also I wanna make sure you're screening,
going forward.
So if you see anyone that is using sort of
unsavory language let's say,
or they're being a little too forward at the beginning,
like they're talking about your body,
or talking about what's gonna happen when you meet up,
that's a little too much too soon.
And then I also want you to be on the lookout
for catfish and scammers.
You are unfortunately in the prime target group
for a lot of financial scams
and I don't want that to happen to you.
So look out for things that could be form letters.
If they send you a message, and if you read it
outside of the context of connecting with this person,
and it could be something that they would say to anyone,
like, "Oh, I love you so much.
"You're so beautiful, I can't wait to see you."
That person could be a scammer.
And so you wanna make sure that you're filtering
before you get in that situation.
That's very good information.
(upbeat music)